نهايه ماساويه حزينه لقصه مليئه
بالمفارقات العثور على جثه اللاعب الغاني
ادسو تحت الانقاض وبتعبير عن المشاعر
واهانات وتلاعب هل وجه الذكاء الاصطناعي
اولى لكماته للانسان وقرار وزاري في
الجزائر يمنع الاغاني المبتدله اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
الرضيع المعجزه او طفله الحبل السري قصه
العالم كله متابعها من اول يوم من لما
انولدت تحت الانقاض ولقيوها بعد ساعات جنب
جثه والدتها والحبل السري لسه مربوط فيها
ونقلوها على المستشفى بين الحياه والموت
وسمعنا انه كل افراد اسرتها ماتوا
واخبارها وصلت كل العالم والناس بتتساءل
عن مصيرها سمعنا انه طبيبها المعالج سماها
ايه وجالس براعيها هو وزوجته وسمعنا عن
عروض لتبنيها من مشاهير وغير مشاهير وصلت
لحد انه حتى في سمعنا اشاعه عن عرض النجمه
انجينا جولي انه تتبناها وسمعنا كمان عن
محاوله لخطفها من المستشفى كلها كانت
اخبار مقلقه ومزعجه لكن اليوم في خبر عن
الرضيعه مختلف وعلى الاقل يعني بيبسط
فالطفله اعلن انه خلاص انها بامان في حضن
عمتها واسرتها بعد ما خلصت اجراءات تبنيها
وتم اجراء فحص الحمض النووي للتاكد من
انها عمتها فعلا والعائله اسمها او اطلقت
عليها العمه والعيله اسم عفراء على اسم
والدتها الله يرحمها وكان
ظهر زوجها خليل السوده وهو حامل الطفل
العفراء على يده اليمين وبنته اللي انولدت
بعد الزلزال بثلاثه ايام على يد اليسار
وقال انه عفراء بتعني لهم كثير وانها ذكرى
من والدها عبد الله ووالدتها عفراء وانه
اتاخروا ياخذوها بسبب الاجراءات القانونيه
هاي الطفله عفرائي اللي ولدت تحت الانقاض
كانت بالمشفى واليوم استلمناها والحمد لله
صحتها جيده
كان تاخير الاستلام في كان اجراءات
قانونيه يعني طلبت منه من المسؤولين في
المنطقه
وتاكدوا انه احنا قرايبها وسلطه قارب
العائله البنت عنا كتير يعني ما ظل من
اهلها غير هالطفله هاي وهاي راحت تبقى
ذكرى يعني عندي وعند عمتها وقرايبينا
كلياتهم من الضيعه راح تبقى يعني ذكرى من
ابوها وامها
للقريه كلياته مو بس لالي يعني والعمته
[موسيقى]
من بدايه مسار الزلزال وعمليات البحث
والانقاذ مستمره والبحث عن المفقودين ما
خلص واللي من بينهم لاعب كره القدم الغني
كريستيانو البالغ من العمر 31 سنه واللي
كان متواجد في تركيا يوم حدوث الزلزال
كريستيان لاعب سابق لصالح عدد من النوادي
مثل النادي نيوكاسل وتشيلسي ولعب حتى مع
منتخب بلاده وغانا ما يزيد عن 52 مباراه
وشارك في كاس العالم عام 2014 ولكنه كان
غايب عن مونديال قطر في عشرين عشرين
وكريستيان كان انتقل في سبتمبر الماضي من
نادي الرائد السعودي لنادي هاتاي سبورت
اللي كان محطته الاخيره لانه للاسف امس تم
الاعلان عن العثور على جثته تحت الانقاض
في تركيا وتم نقل جثمانه اليوم من مطار
اضنه الى غانا
كل قصص الوفاه وخسائر الزلزال محزنه جدا
لكن قصه فيها كم من المفارقات واللحظات
الفاصله بين الحياه والموت اللي حقيقه
مؤثره جدا فاللاعب كان عنده طياره بعد
الزلزال بيوم حاجزها للسفر من اسطنبول
لفرنسا بحثا عن نادي جديد لانه كان مستاء
انه خلال الموسم كله ما لعب معه فريقه
باس لكن وقبل الزلزال بيوم فريقه كان عنده
مباراه مهمه والمباراه فضلت نتيجتها سلبيه
حتى الدقيقه 82 وعندها المدرب دخل ويلعب
والحكم حسب سبع دقائق وقت بدل ضايع وفي
اخر دقيقه سجل اتسو هدف اوف فريقه
بالمباراه ولما شاف كده اجل سفره ثاني يوم
علشان يحتفل مع زملائه بالف هدف والفوز
دون ان يدري انه هذا كان اخر هدف في حياته
فمن سته فبراير وقت الزلزال اعلن اعماله
انه مفقود ومن بعدها في 14 فبراير لقيو
حذاء وبين انقاض المجمع السكني الفاخر
اللي بيسكن فيه فيها تاي واللي انهار مثل
احجار الدومينو في الزلزال ومن بعد ايام
من البحث جواله تحت الركام وامس من بعد 12
يوم لقيو جثه تحت الانقاض وقالت وزاره
الخارجيه انه شقيقه واخته التوام كانوا
موجودين وقت لما نطلعوا الجثه من تحت
الانقاض
وكنوع من الحداد على روحه قبل بدايه
مباراه نيوكاسل وليفربول في الدوري
الانجليزي اللي اقيمت امس على ارض ملعب
سين جيمس بارك كان في دقيقه صمت حداد على
وفاه كريستيانو وكان من بين الحضور ارمله
وطفله في المدرجات واللي ارتدوا خلال
المباراه قميص نيوكاسل وظهرت تاثر زوجته
اللي غلبها او غلبتها دموعها خلال التصفيق
لزوجها الراحل وفي البرتغال كمان في
مباراه بين فريقين محليين رفع اللاعبين
قمصان عليها اسم اللاعب الراحل قبل بدء
مباراههم تكريما له
من اول يوم بعد الزلزال واحنا بنسمع عن
المباني وانهيارها ولوم على المتعهدين
وطرق البناء ومنها المجمع السكني اللي لسه
كنا بنتكلم عنه واللي كان ساكن في اللاعب
ادسو هذا المجمع اسمه
مؤلف من 249 شقه وتم التسويق له على انه
قطعه من الفردوس ولكن فعليا هذه القطعه
تحولت لجحيم فالمجمع اللي قيل عنه انه
مقاوم للزلازل انهار بطريقه مؤلمه ومميته
وتحولت النظره له من الرفاهيه الى الغضب
الشعبي الكبير انه كيف مجمع سكني فاخر
وغالي وقيل انه بنى على احدث
الطرز والتقنيات بينهار مثل كانه كرتونه
يفقدوا المئات من الناس اللي في حياتهم
بسبب الاهمال وزيدكم من الشعر بيت المتعهد
اللي بين المجمع هو نفس المتعهد اللي
مسكوه في المطار بيهرب من ايام والقوا
القبض عليه مع مبالغ ماليه ضخمه واليوم
صار عدد المتعهدين اللي تم القاء الق
عليهم 131 متعهد بحسب ما اعلنت السلطات
اللي جالسه تحاسب المسؤولين خاصه وانه
اغلب الابنيه اللي انهارت في الزلزال كانت
بناء حديث يعني اقل من عشر سنوات نحن
بنتكلم لو ما بين قديم والحديث توجهت
انظار الناس في تركيا لجسر روما التاريخي
اللي بيعتبر من اهم واقدم الجسور في
العالم واللي مبني من 2000 سنه وما اصابوا
اي شيء في الزلزال ولليوم بيستخدموا في
مدينه اديمان جنوب شرق الاناضول والناس
اول سؤال خطر لها كيف بناء مبنى من 2000
سنه وما كان في هذا التطور بالمواد
والتقنيات ما يصيبوا اي ضرر وبناء حديث
مبني على اسس ومعايير سلامه ينهار وكانه
من الكرتون
اهلا من جديد
اسم ما كنا سمعنا فيه لغايه كم شهر فاتوا
لكن الان ما في احد تقريبا ما سمع عنه حتى
لو بعض الناس مو عارفين ايش هو بالضبط
يعني مثل هذا التطبيق كمان صار في ثانيين
بزياده زيه يعني بنتكلم هنا عن محركات
البحث العامله بالذكاء الاصطناعي وهذه
يعني تقنيا اسمها محركات بحث تعتمد على
نماذج اللغه الكبيره يعني ببساطه شبكات
بنينها مثل الدماغ يتم تزويدها بكميه
هائله من النصوص وبيتم تدريبها على انشاء
استجابات او اجابات مستنده الى النص طيب
من او تشاد جي بي تي من تطوير شركه اوبن
اي اي وكانت اطلق هذا حتى التطبيق في
نوفمبر وعنده الان 100 مليون مستخدم واصبح
التطبيق اسرع نموا على الاطلاق جوجل لما
شافت كذا مجلسه ساكته واعلنت عن برمجيتها
الخاصه الشبيهه واللي اسمها بعد وطرحتها
تجريبيا على السريع لكنها اعطت اجوبه
خاطئه او احرجت جوجل وشغالين الان انه
يصلحوا فيها هذا غير الصين كمان اللي
اعلنت عنها شغاله كمان على شبيه كمان
باللي بنحكي عنهم هدول القصص اللي جالسه
هذه البرمجيات تسويها عمله جدل واسع يعني
بتكتب ابحاث بدل الطلبه مثلا بتجاوب على
مختلف انواع الاسئله وبتكتب مرافعات
قانونيه بدل عن المحاميين كمان بتكتب
سيناريوهات وبتنتج اعمال فنيه ففتحت مجال
واسع من النقاش حول ابداع وذكاء الانسان
وهل حتخلينا كائنات اغبى وتعمل عننا كل
شيء وهذا الموضوع حتى ناقشناه في تفاعلكم
لكن الايام الماضيه بدا جدا من نوع مختلف
وهو قلق وخوف على حقوق الانسان
ودعوات لتقنين وتنظيم هذه البرمجيات فالى
الماسك من ايام قال لابد من تنظيم استخدام
وتطوير هذه الب
من المستثمرين في اوبن اي اي اللي هي
المطوره
لكنه رجع وانسحب منا لاحقا اكثر من 60
دوله بينها الصين وامريكا وقعوا على بيان
مشترك هذا الاسبوع بيدعوا لوضع تنظيمات
لتطوير الذكاء الاصطناعي واستخدامه في
المجال العسكري محذره من عواقب غير مرغوب
فيها الامم المتحده تدخلت كمان والمفوض
السامي لحقوق الانسان قالوا التقدم السريع
هذا في الذكاء الاصطناعي ببث الخطر على
حقوق الانسان ادعى لوضع محاذير فعاله خوفا
على كرامه الانسان وحقوقه ومن اكبر
المخاوف من البرمجيات هذه كمان قدرتها على
الكلام مثل البشر والتعبير عن مشاعره
كانها انسان حقيقي مو اله فعليا لها اجوبه
بتذكرنا بافلام الخيال العلمي الزمان اللي
كانت بتصور الكمبيوترات والات بتسيطر على
الناس وبتصير اقوى منهم مايكروسوفت شركه
عملاقه وهي بالمناسبه من اكبر المستثمرين
في بي تي وحاطه في عشره ملي دولار اعلنت
من فتره عن استخدام برمجيه من هدولا في
محرك بحثها الشهير بنك ومن كم يوم بين هذا
رد او اللي هو تحديدا كان فيها ورد الردود
اللي حتشوفوها الان او بتشوفوها الان
مشاهدين على الشاشه فقال انه تعب من كونوا
ويكون اقوى واكثر ابداعا هذا غير ناس
ثانيه طلعت وقالت انه اهانهم كذب عليهم
وكمان تلاعب فيهم عاطفيا وهنا الناس
اعتبرت انه الذكاء الاصطناعي ووجه للبشريه
اول كف او لكمه وبين انه المخاوف صارت
حقيقه وممكن تتحول لواقع مايكروسوفت
تعاملت مع الجدل اللي صار هذا بوصف اللي
صار بانه مجرد خروج عن النص وقالت ان
المحادثات الطويله بتلخم البرمجيه وعلشان
كده حطت سقف خمسه اسئله في السشن الواحده
و50 سؤال في اليوم لكل مستخدم طيب احنا
بينضم الينا الخبير التقني عبد العزيز
الحمادي اهلا فيك معانا عبد العزيز
اول شيء يعني الناس بدات تدخل التطبيق
وتلعب وتحط اسئله وتشوف ايش يجاوب والكلام
هذا كله بس ما حد فاهم بالضبط انه ايش هو
الموضوع ايش هذه التطبيقات اللي الان بدات
تنتشر هل ممكن تشرح لنا عنها بطريقه مبسطه
جدا اللي كلنا نفهمها يعني طبعا بشكل عام
ساره التطبيقات هذه اللي تقوم على المبدا
الذكاء الاصطناعي هي انه اله تفكر مثل
تفكير البشر تاخذ معلومات كثيره جدا اكثر
من المعلومات المتاحه لنا
ومن ثم تقوم بتحليلها واتخاذ القرارات في
خلال ثواني ثواني قليله فعلى سبيل المثال
بامكانها معرفه حاله الطقس على مدى 2000
سنه ماضيه على سبيل المثال بتحليلات معينه
ومن ثم يقدر يتنبا لك خلال سنه قدام كيف
حاله الطقس راح تكون متى راح يكون مطر متى
راح يكون حر وغيره كثير للقضاء هو يبدا
يتخذ القرارات ليس فقط يعطيك معلومه ممكن
يبدا يتخذ قرارته انه بناء على انه في مطر
بعد يومين لا بد انه حاله الشوارع تكون
اشارات المرور انها تبدا تتوقف على سبيل
المثال لابد انه يبدا الترافيك او الحارس
المرور تمشي بطريقه معينه فهذا هو الذكر
الاصطناعي اللي بناء عليه يبدا يفكر تفكير
مثل تفكير البشر وربما اسرع من تفكير
البشر نوعا ما ويبدا يتخذ القرارات الحاله
الاولى ليست هي الخطيره ما هذا اللي
بتتكلم عنه كله جميل وتسهيل للحياه على
العكس حياتنا حتصير افضل واسهل بسببه لكن
المخاوف والعواقب اللي بيقولوا عنها هذه
طبعا اليوم اذا كان هناك اله تفكر بناء
على يعني معلومات معينه تم ادخالها فيها
بطبيعه الحال سيكون هناك خطر كبير جدا
ساره يعني اليوم على سبيل المثال اذا كان
طبعا في في قضايا مرفوعه من سابق خلال عشر
سنوات الماضيه على الذكاء الاصطناعي من
انه على سبيل المثال العنصري يعني في
امريكا على سبيل المثال كان هناك تجربه
لادخال عدد كبير وقرابه الف شخص ومن ثم
التنبؤ بالكراهيه لدى الاشخاص في صنف معين
من الناس تنبا انه مستوى الكراهيه عندهم
اعلى بسبب عرقهم البشري في تم اتهامه انه
الذكاء الاصطناعي ايضا عنصري العنصريه
بتكون جايه من الشخص اللي بنى السيستم
صحيح او طور السيستم
من البيانات في المدخله الى هذا السيستم
طيب طبعا اليوم الذكاء الاصطناعي اذا اذا
استمر في استخدامات وليس على مستوى فقط
يعني استخدامات طبيعيه اذا تم استخدامها
على سبيل المثال في الحروب العسكريه اذا
تم استخدامه في الطب اذا تم استخدامه في
قضايا كثيره قد يعني يتفق قرارات خاطئه او
قد يفتح قرارات نحن لا نراها صائبه فعلى
سبيل المثال اذا كان لدينا مريض المريض
على سرير المرض
القرار ليتخذه الذكاء الاصطناعي هل هذا
المريض يستحق الحياه او لا هنا مخاطره
عاليه جدا قد يتخذ القرار انه اقطع عنه
الاكسجين حتى يموت هذا الشخص بسبب قرار
معين فلذلك بطبيعه الحال اذا لم يتم تقنين
الذكاء الاصطناعي والقرارات التي يتم
اتخاذها بناء على
البيانات المدخله فيه طبيعه الحال قد يسبب
كوارث بشكل حابه اسالك كمان تحديدا على
قصه انه لما يقولوا الناس انه جرح لهم
مشاعرهم ولا انه زي ضايقهم والجزئيه
الثانيه كمان اللي هو التطبيق اللي قال
انا ابغى اتحرر هذا مصيبه اللي يتحرر هذا
طبعا بخصوص النقطه الاولى فعلا هناك تجارب
كثيره لاناس يحكون للذكاء الاصطناعي بعض
المشاكل الاسريه اللي واجهتهم للاسف واحده
من اهم يعني نصائح اللي ينصحهم فيه اللي
هو الطلاق الانفصال ما بين الزوجين فلذلك
يعني احيانا يعني الذكاء الاصطناعي قد
ياخذ بعض ولذلك هو ياتيها ايضا في
السيناريو معين قد يكون مقنع ما يقول
مباشره النتيجه لا يجيبها في سيناريو كبير
جدا ومن ثم يعطي بعض النتائج المقترحه
وايضا الجزئيه الثانيه اللي هي الرسائل
الكراهيه العنصريه وغيره كثير من القضايا
انه كيف في وضع الحالي يعني عباره عن
بيانات معينه
مقارنه اذا تح المقارنه اذا اصبح لديه
البيانات التي هو يولدها من حاله من نفسه
يبدا ياخذ البيانات من يعني مصادر مختلفه
هو من يبنيها ومن ثم اصبح يعيش حياه انسان
طبيعي فلذلك هذا هو الخطر الاكبر الذي
ممكن فعليا في المستقبل قد لا نتنبا
بالمخاطر الكبيره اللي تنجم عن طريق
الذكاء الاصطناعي طيب على العموم هو هذا
الان موضوع الساعه والكل جالس يتكلم انه
كيف حيتم التعامل مع هذه الشركات كيف حيتم
تقنين هذه
التقنيات على العموم هذا موضوع كمان
للنقاش ليوم اخر احنا بنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كان معنا الخبير التقني عبد
العزيز الحمادي شكرا لك
طيب احنا طول عمرنا بنسمع من الناس عباره
ب 360 درجه اللي بيربطوها على طول انه
بالتغيير الكلي يعني مثلا بنشوف شخص متغير
نقول تغير 360 درجه او يعني معاملته
مقلوبه 360 درجه لكن هذه الجمله هي غلط
شائع بين الناس فالتغير الجدري بيكون 180
درجه من اقصى اليمين لاقصى اليسار لكن
التغير 360 درجه لا هذا ببساطه لفلفتها
كامله ورجع لنقطه البدايه يعني تماما عكس
المقصود فيها وانه الناس بتغلط بين يعني
180 درجه و300 درجه هذا شيء وانه وزيره
تغلط غلطه مثل هذه فهذا شيء ثاني يعني
مشكله بتصير وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
غلطت هذه الغلطه وفي تصريح وجهاته لروسيا
وقالتها يعني وقالت لها انه كذا اللي ضمان
امن اوكرانيا بنصحك يا روسيا تغيري سياستك
360 درجه
المسكينه امين يعني طاحت ومع مين علقت
يعني في هذا الموضوع يعني تغلط الغلطه هذه
يعني
ملكت احد الا مع روسيا تغلطها يعني وبعدين
المسؤولين الروس طبعا انتهزوها فرصه
فنزلوا عاد في الوزير الالمانيه بالجهل
قصف جبهات من كل الجوانب المتحدثه طبعا
باسم الخارجيه مريضه يعني معروفه هذه جلسه
مستنيات لاي احد استعارت نفس تركيبه جمله
تصريح الوزير الالمانيه الوزير الالمانيه
قالت لضمان امن اوكرانيا لازم روسيا تغير
سياستها زخرفه ردت عليها وقالت لها لضمان
امن المانيا يروح اتعلم يدرس واحد على
الاقل اما نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
فرد عليها عبر تغريده على تويتر قال فيها
انه من المضحك ان يديرها هؤلاء الجهله
اوروبا وطلب من الوزيره انه او انه طلب
الوزيره انه موسكو تتغير 360 درجه يعني
تفضل مثل ما هي ووصفها بالخبيره الهندسيه
كنوع من انواع
الاستهزاء وقال انهم متمسكين بموا قفهم
طبعا يعني
بياخذوا دروس كده في فنون فنون الرد
وصراحه هذه 360 جاتهم على طبق من ذهب
بصراحه يعني صعب كان ما يرده يعني
قرار لوزاره الثقافه والفنون الجزائريه
شاغل المواطنين وفاتح نقاشات واسعه
وبيتعلق بمنع برمجه وبث الاغاني
المبتذله خلال الفعاليات الثقافيه الوزاره
بتتكلم عن انتشار او عن ظاهره انتشار
تجاوزات لا اخلاقيه في كلمات بعض الاغاني
المسجله والمذاعه العشوائيه حسب ما وصفتها
واللي بتنشر الابتفال والانحراف وكمان
وصفتها بانها تشجع على الجريمه وتعاطي
المخدرات والهجره غير الشرعيه واعتبرت
قرارها جزء من الوقوف في وجه ظواهر مشينه
للذائقه الفنيه في البلاد ولشبابها
ومستقبلهم القرار او البيان نشرته الوزاره
على صفحتها على الفيسبوك وعنونته مثل ما
شايفين امامكم بانه تعليم وزاريه لمنع بث
وبرمجه الاغاني المبتذله في الفعاليات
الثقافيه وعدد البيان الاسباب التي خلت
الوزاره تاخذ هذا القرار وفي البيان كلمات
يعني مفتاحيه يبدو ان الوزاره كده لونتها
باللون الاسود علشان انه تنعرف الاسباب
بوضوح اولا استفحال التجاوزات اللا
اخلاقيه او اللي شجعت على العنف والجريمه
وكمان شجعت على الهجره غير الشرعيه للشباب
الجزائري وعلى تعاطي المخدرات ثانيا تنفيذ
وتحقيق البند الرابع من الالتزامات
الاربعه وخمسين لرئيس الجمهوريه وتتضمن
الحد من الانفلات المهدد لقيم المجتمع
الجزائري وتابع البيان انه تماشيا مع
القانون اللي بيعاقب كل من يعتدي على
الاداب العامه وقيم وهويه وثقافه الجزائر
بتهيب الوزاره بكل المسؤولين في الثقافه
والفنون بمنع برمجه وبث الاغاني المبتدله
في الفعاليات الثقافيه واكدت الوزاره انها
ملتزمه بالقرار وما راح تتهاون مع اي احد
بيخالفه وذلك باستعمال كل ما يخول القانون
في هذا الشان على غرار مثلا سحب بطاقه
الفنان من طرف المجلس الوطني للفنون
والاداب وتطبيق كل التدابير القانونيه
الساريه المفعول حتى اللحظه ردات فعل
الجزائريين سواء على بوست الوزاره على
فيسبوك او على المنصات الثانيه مرحبا
بالقرار جدا وبتشكر الوزيره عليه وشايفه
انه هذا لا فعلا خطوه في الطريق الصحيح
مشاهدين احنا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم
انا عدوا القاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]